armenia has accused azerbaijan of trying
to advance into its territory after
deadly fighting between the countries
broke out overnight now armenia's prime
minister has phoned world leaders to
demand what he's calling an adequate
reaction
armenia released this footage which the
defense ministry says shows azerbaijani
troops trying to enter armenia both
sides claimed their armies suffered
casualties in fighting at the border the
neighboring countries went to war in the
1990s and in 2020 over the disputed
region of nagorno-karabakh
i will talk to an expert about the
latest developments in a minute but
before we do let's have a quick look
back at the context of the fighting
the heavy military presence in
nagorno-karabakh is part of everyday
life in the enclave
in recent years the disputed region has
seen fighting flare on a regular basis
located in the south caucasus
nagorno-karabakh is internationally
recognized as part of azerbaijan but is
controlled by ethnic armenian forces
backed by armenia
the conflict dates back to the
dissolution of the soviet union ever
since armenia and azerbaijan have
claimed nagorno-karabakh as their own
territory
a so-called frozen conflict that remains
unresolved four decades later
the conflict has international
ramifications turkey has expressed its
support of azerbaijan while russia has
provided armenia with military equipment
joshua kuchera is a journalist who
specializes in the region he edits the
caucasus coverage at the news website
eurasia net and he joins us now from
warsaw welcome to dw we've just had a
look back at the historical skirmishes
in the nagorno-karabakh region can you
tell us what makes this round of
fighting different
uh sure well the significance of this
round is that it's
uh the the targets azerbaijan's targets
this time are in armenia proper
uh previously the fighting has been
concentrated mostly in and around
nagorno-karabakh
which is internationally recognized as
azerbaijani territory
these attacks are along
armenian communities along the the
border
inside armenia which would represent a
significant escalation uh in in
azerbaijan's
targeting
we're hearing that armenia's phoned a
number of world leaders
asking for help this morning is anyone
responding
well the key uh
actor here is russia uh uh prime
minister uh nicole pashanyan spoke with
uh russian president vladimir putin this
morning
asked for russia to intervene based on
the the mutual defense pact that the two
countries have
uh this has never been uh exercised in
the past because like i said all the the
fighting has gone on on
azerbaijani territory now that it's
spread apparently uh to armenian
territory this is going to be a big
question if the fighting continues
russia according to that treaty
would be obligated to come to armenia's
defense
of course russia in the last few days
has been
suffering its own military defeats in
ukraine and i think that that probably
explains why this offensive was launched
now
but anyway that's going to be the key
the key question is how russia responds
so far they've acknowledged armenia's
request for for assistance
but have not uh indicated how they're
going to respond
you mentioned ukraine does does all this
mean that we could see a second fully
fledged war in the post uh soviet world
uh well at this point it's really hard
to say i mean most of the times that
azerbaijan has escalated things it has
to do with pressuring armenia
uh to continue to carry out the terms of
the 2020 ceasefire
agreement or to work towards a
a comprehensive peace agreement so kind
of military pressure to get diplomatic
results i mean this is a big military
escalation
uh whether it's to continue to get more
diplomatic results or whether
they have some bigger intentions it's
too early to say so far
something we'll be watching closely
journalist joshua kuchera thank you so
much
you